in a stunning revelation US intelligence
has learned that Russia is considering
turning over leaker Edward Snowden to
the United States as a sort of gift to
president Donald Trump highly sensitive
intelligence of reports say that
Russia's deliberations about this are
pointing in the direction of considering
whether to send Snowden back to the US
and this is the idea of course that
Russia is trying to maybe ingratiate
themselves with Trump by doing this it's
been corroborated by multiple sources in
the intelligence community Donald Trump
of course called Edward Snowden a spy a
traitor and even tweeted back in October
of 2013 that maybe Edward Snowden should
be executed
Snowden's ACLU lawyer Ben wizner told
NBC News they're unaware of plans that
would send Snowden back to the United
States Edward Snowden though saying hey
guys this confirms I'm not a Russian spy
since Russia would never give me up if I
were actually a Russian spy he sent out
a couple of tweets one saying finally
irrefutable evidence that I never
cooperated with Russian Intel no country
trades away spies as the rest would fear
that they're next he also said something
similar to Katie Couric during a Yahoo
News interview not that long ago let's
take a look at that there is a lot of
talk up there including among top
ranking intelligence officials that
Vladimir Putin may hand you over to the
United States as a good well well
gesture to the Trump administration how
concerned / nervous are you about that
possibility I'm actually kind of
encouraged encouraged for completely
different reasons it wasn't so many
years ago the people were saying
disguised Russian spy what would the
implications be well former deputy
national security adviser one Zarate
says be cautious because this could be a
win-win for russia if they did get
anything from Edward Snowden in terms of
information not that he was necessarily
cooperating but he has been there for a
while
they already would have and then they
could also use this to gain further
leverage over Donald Trump we don't
actually know how much leverage they
have because we haven't seen Trump's
taxes and because we're still in the
process of confirming the content of
that Russian blackmail file White House
has no comment on this so far the
Justice Department said they would
welcome Edward Snowden's return to the
United States you can be sure Pat that
if Russia sends him back no future
informants will make similar deals to go
to Russia as long as they're remotely
smart I would imagine though that Russia
may be more reluctant to send him back
now because as the Trump Russia story
seems to be getting more credibility
that would just kind of play into the
narrative that they were colluding
together so I could see them not wanting
to do it in that case well there's
another interpretation of why they might
want to do it and it goes beyond just oh
they want to curry favor with Trump okay
maybe I mean that's pretty simplistic in
it and it would actually probably work
because of who Donald Trump is but they
could also return Snowden to the US to
trigger protests because you know that
the second that Snowden is indicted and
prosecution begins because Snowden has
huge support from many factions in the
United States it will cause yet another
round of massive protests on the street
think back to my interview last week
with foreign relations and information
warfare expert Molly McHugh check out
her article Putin's real long game the
triggering of unrest and very visible
unrest would be a really good reason for
Russia to return Snowden to the US and
it would be a terrible thing if Edward
Snowden was extradited given that not
only has the president called for his
execution but also CIA director Mike
Pompeo
yeah and aside from what your opinion is
of Edward Snowden and of course Edward
Snowden as a leaker who was exposing
things that were legal by statute we can
disagree with that but not a
whistleblower in the literal sense the
fact that numerous of numerous officials
who are currently in power suggested
that this guy should be killed
absolutely concerning
it's not about the micro it's about the
macro here chaos instability the us of
being cast as unreliable all creating a
context where Vladimir Putin and Russia
can be seen as more powerful more clever
on the international geopolitical stage
today's show is made possible in part by
blue apron not all ingredients are
created equal fresh high-quality
ingredients make a really big difference
so it's important to know where your
food comes from which you would know
with blue apron you also get the exact
right amount of each ingredient for the
recipes you're cooking so you don't end
up throwing food away which I absolutely
hate doing and for under ten bucks per
person per meal you can get
easy-to-follow recipes with
pre-portioned ingredients delivered and
because again blue apron ships the exact
amount of each ingredient you need you
don't waste food some of the meals
available this month include cashew
chicken stir-fry with Tango mandarins
and jasmine rice food on noodle soup
with miso and soft-boiled eggs I've got
that one coming next week and I look
forward to cooking it and crispy
barramundi with quinoa and roasted
carrot salad you can check out this
week's menu get your first three meals
for free with free shipping by going to
blue apron dot-com slash Pakman that's
blue apron comm slash PA k ma n